so today i want to talk about five
things that i wished someone told me
before i started my phd so if you're
doing your phd right now you will
probably recognize these five things or
if you're thinking about doing your phd
these five things will probably help
guide you into making a better choice so
hi i'm shalotta fraser a second year phd
student in computational neuroscience at
the donors institute in the netherlands
right now
and today i want to talk about these
five things that i wish
someone told me before i started my phd
so the first thing is that the most
important choice you will make during
the start of your phd and what kind of
topic you want to do is probably the
choice of your supervisor so your
supervisor is the person that will
decide if you graduate and sign what
kind of papers you can publish what kind
of subjects you can research and also
what kind of money is allocated towards
your research so what kind of resources
you can get and that is why your
supervisor is the number one thing you
must pick right and i've seen before
that people choose based on the
university for example the university
name or based on the fame of some lab or
the location and i think all these
things are valid but what is more
important is that you have a good
supervisor so if your supervisor is
narcissistic or only wants his name on
the paper or has a very strong opinion
on what kind of research you can do you
will be very limited in your phd journey
whereas if your supervisor is
accommodating a very supportive and
allocates a lot of resources towards you
even if he is from a smaller lab your
phd experience and results that you get
from your phd are probably so much more
valuable and that's why i would really
recommend before starting your phd if
you can for example start a little
project with your supervisor so a little
lab rotation before you officially start
or if this is not possible to
for example interview some students that
have worked with him or her before such
that you get a really good insight into
what kind of person your supervisor is
and if for example your communication
skills match or if how you want to be
supervised matches with your supervisor
yeah and i think this will really make
your phd journey so much more smooth if
you have someone that matches you in
that sense because it is the person that
you will be most close with during your
phd journey and the second thing no one
really talks about is the importance of
writing papers and also how the paper
writing system is kind of broken so in
general your entire academic career will
be based on an age index and your age
index is basically correlated to how
many papers you published and how much
those papers got cited but of course
this system is quite easily to be rigged
and to be hacked so what big
universities for example do or big labs
do is they cite each other's papers such
that these labs have higher age indexes
and i think in general this is extremely
bad and almost everyone agrees with the
fact that the paper writing system is
broken in a sense but what no one really
talks about is the fact that you will
still be pushed as a phd student to
write in these big journals that are
known to be varied and that are known to
have faulty systems so if you are not
comfortable with playing this game i
would really recommend to look at
smaller laps that are less focused on
this kind of fame rigging but if you're
willing to play along a little bit just
keep in the back of your mind that this
is just part of being in academia and
hopefully it will change in the coming
years with the new generation and
another thing i think people don't talk
about enough as soon as you start your
phd you kind of have to think about what
you want to do after because i've seen a
lot of students that are graduating
right now that don't know for sure what
they want to do after and one of the
thing things is if you know beforehand
that you want to stay in academia you
really have to think about how to get
your funding after your phd for postdoc
and funding is based on for example how
many papers you wrote but also how many
teaching hours you had and if you know
this beforehand you can schedule your
phd in such a manner that you have some
teaching hours and also to choose
projects that are easily publishable but
if you know you want to go to industry
afterwards your phd journey would
probably look a little bit different i
would for example then recommend to do
some courses that are suitable for the
skills they ask in industry so for
example i know right now in industry
that i perhaps want to apply for they
ask java coding skills and i'm coding
right now in python but i know in my
final year of my phd i will probably
take a course in java coding and get
that up to speed such that i have a
smoother journey into applying for
certain industry jobs and the fourth
thing no one really talks about and
especially nowadays is that your social
circle during your phd matters so much
and i think your social circle is
everyone including the people you meet
in university but also the people
outside of university so for example
your family or your friends from before
university and i think people don't
really recognize enough how important
this support system will be during your
phd because there will be moments that
you're very tired or you feel very
lonely or you're not sure you want to
continue and this support system is
really the system that allows you to
keep strong and keep going so i see
around me that the phd students that do
the best are usually not the students
that are most motivated or that i have
really strong working ethic
although this is of course also really
important but it's usually the students
that actually have a really strong
support system that also really supports
their goals so for example they have
fellow phd students around them that can
help study and that can help motivate
each other to make those last few hours
before a paper deadline and the last
thing which i think is most important is
probably that the nature of your
research is such that nothing will
probably go exactly according to plan
and that is why you kind of need to plan
to feel early and fast at the beginning
because one of the most important things
you will learn during your phd is that
failure is a part of it and how to
handle failure will be probably one of
the things you will incorporate quite
quickly so that's why i would recommend
especially at the beginning of your phd
to not really focus on one project but
to have several projects and make them
kind of short but snappy and then when
you notice that one project is probably
has a lot of potential to focus on that
instead of putting all your eggs in one
basket so to say and something else that
i wish i had done a little bit more once
i started was to write up everything
even if an experiment failed because
i've seen before that papers were
published on things that i had done but
for them it worked but for me it failed
and i think it's really good to
sometimes get insight in exactly what
point you did differently or perhaps you
can write these researchers saying i did
something very similar this is my code
perhaps we can collaborate on the next
project so if you're struggling a little
bit with your phd i made another video
on some tips and tricks on how to
continue so to say and otherwise see you
next week
bye